And then before we get on to any tips and tricks, we'll talk about how to render your
sequences out.
So let's look at rendering in sequence now.
So the animatic creation is super straightforward.
We can just drag the board sequence actor into an empty level sequence and it will automatically
add the board sequence to a shot track that you're ready to render the finished animatic
with.
So we have two different tools that I'd disposal here.
We have the movie render queue and the movie scene capture, which is a legacy tool which
is being deprecated, but it is also great for rendering out videos with AVI format.
So it's a general purpose capture for cinematic output supports custom render passes HDR export
but doesn't support high resolution scaling.
So it's currently the only the option for AVI files.
So that's what we'll go ahead and use that being said, if you're using future versions
of Unreal Engine.amp 5.1, just go ahead and check out what the current movie render options
are and use a tool that's most appropriate for what you need there.
So with the HDR exporting, we have got export HDR data in open EXR files.
We've got specify the HDR compression quality and then the capture gamut depending on what
you need.
And then also with the render passes, we limit render pass options.
So it is not render layers.
And then just a quick note on the bottom here, at least one render pass must be selected
or all render pass options will be rendered.
So this is what we end up with here.
I'll just play a quick sequence for you to see.